hey everybody Sean McGinnis and kevin
van or here and like a lot of you folks
we spent the weekend catching up on the
Destiny alpha on PlayStation 4 Kevin
what were your initial impressions
better plan well actually I had a really
good time yeah I do have my quibbles and
I'm sure we'll be getting into those in
a few moments but overall I really liked
it I think he the shooting model is
really solid it's interesting because I
see a lot of people drawing parallels to
quarter lands but actually I have to say
I like Destiny's tone a lot better than
I like borderlands and I like the
shooting model itself a lot more than I
like so overall I had a really good time
yeah i mean the borderlands comparison
is something a lot of people are making
but to me like what he also need about
destiny is that it's so much broader in
scope you have those RPG mechanics like
you have in
borderlands but like just enough of the
world is so gorgeous and then you add in
like the social elements running into
other players out in the wild and just
like the way of those weapons feel like
Borderlands has eight billion different
permutations of their guns but calling
them aren't a huge fan of any of them
right um but the weapons and destiny
feel really good don't they yeah they
feel they feel super good and I I mean I
have to say it going into it I sort of
expected the shooting to feel more or
less like Halo and that's not really the
case at all these weapons feel very
different to me from any of halo so with
that in mind what would you take on the
strike mission because the Alpha is a
pretty narrow sliver of content you have
that initial story mission you have that
middle mission where you're just kind of
exploring out there doing this big
handful of quest but then you have the
third one which is really what you're
working your way up to it's kind of
interesting it's like a multi-tier MMO
raid yeah so you have the the first
stretch which is just you and your two
teammates going through the the more or
less larger area as you make your way to
a facility and go into an interior and
it ends with this bit so you have this
little floating computer thing goes and
it has the voice of Avalon astir mm-hmm
pretty complex I'll need time and it's
it's it's super interesting this the way
it the way the first part of it sort of
ends because as it hacks into this
computer you have you and your teammates
have to fend off this overwhelming wave
of enemies and it's not just one wait
it's three waves of increasingly oh
whelming enemies one of which is this
wizard that just takes so many bullets
to bring down and it's sort of
relentless it surprised me because I
wasn't really struck by the game being
challenging anywhere else and then
suddenly it was a great challenge to
have to overcome even just the first
part of this let alone the second two
bits that come after both of which are
essentially boss fights yeah this was
the part in which became really get
serious and you and your fire team have
to behave as a group because if you're
all just running around willy-nilly
you're kind of get yourself killed so
fast and you always need to have that
one guy who's still alive and able to
revive people or stay alive long enough
for that spawn counter to tick all the
way down you get jump back in automatic
one nice thing though is that revival is
very quick so one thing that is sort of
actually sort of a pet peeve of mine and
other shooters that do have revival
mechanics is that you have to stand
there for a really long time I get dudes
off the ground in this case you go over
you just hold the button for a few
seconds and you're up an atom no no
worse for the wear at all so it's it's
nice and snappy so reviving other
players doesn't feel like a chore like
it does in a lot of other games so you
like that first sequence of the strike
mission I don't think either one of us
really like the second sequence all that
much which is the big devil Walker which
is kind of like a giant armored spider
so I've done the strike mission I guess
three times now
and it's it strikes me as though it's
just a bullet sponge there is a way of
shooting out its legs and getting into
open and shooting it sweet spot but
every time I've played it it seems to be
the more common tactic just to fill it
with bullets until it dies yeah and it's
weird because it's not a particularly
frustrating encounter it's just really
long yes this thing lasts forever and at
least in my experience you just kind of
like turtle yourself up in some little
corner the level you pop out you fire
for a while you drain all the ammo that
you have wait for those other guys to
respond so you can kill them grab more
ammo and then you just keep turtling up
and trying to shoot the devil walker for
the 10 minutes it takes to kill yeah
it's it's really strange in the the
bullet sponge kind of way and actually
if there's one gameplay issue I have
with with the Destiny elf as a whole it
was that sense of things being more
bullets fun than they were actually a
real like a real challenge it wasn't so
much I felt like I was having to stay on
my toes as much as I just had to stay
focused and had to just keep at it and
the devil Walker is interesting because
elsewhere in the Alpha that particular
enemy is actually used in a public event
yeah he actually comes down and it's an
opportunity for
kind of like just come together out of
the blue and team up and take them on
and there when you have a bunch of
players it's actually a much more
interesting fight because you get more
of a group sense but in this strike
mission when it's just three of you it
takes much longer to get along it really
does and that of course that leads into
the third leg of the fight which is the
one against seppings right did I get it
right something like yeah yeah so so
this is this is actually more
interesting than the double Walker at
least because you've got this giant orb
that sort of shoots lasers out of it
plus you you're being you know swarmed
by cords of normal enemies but only
after you although after a while they
get pretty tough to you've got a couple
of those shielded enemies in particular
they can just take seemingly forever to
bring down again it's a lot about the
bullet sponge and but the orbs really
interesting because it'll teleport in
two different places and move around and
suddenly I'll be standing there trying
to whittle down all the regular guys and
suddenly it teleports and it's right on
top of me and I gotta move and what am I
gonna do oh my god so yeah there's I
like that benefit of the fight there
were times where I really just felt
suddenly overwhelmed and I had to run
and get my breath and try to tackle it
yeah I really like the separate run
battle a lot more than the devil offer
one because like you said it was just
more dynamic there's more
it wasn't just you popping out and
shooting it it didn't feel like a war of
attrition with the devil walk like there
are actual tactics and teamwork elements
at play which is what I like about it
plus you end that and you gain some
levels there and you get some loot which
is nice because that leads us into the
third point about destiny which is
multiplayer all that loot that you can
capture in campaign
use that multiplayer which is kind of
one of the interesting things about this
if there's one other thing that I think
doesn't quite work two destinies benefit
at this stage anyway is the voice acting
in the writing so for example there's
one place where you you utter the line I
have a bad feeling about this during the
first story mission and my eyes just
wait you utter that or Peter I think buh
i think peter dinklage utters it and of
course he's the voice of your ghost and
so that that that he's a bit of dialogue
right there is so cliched at this point
that it's hard not to write notice it
and most of the dialogue continues
there's the moment where he's hacking
into the computer and then at one point
he says well i'll try to go faster why
were you not going fast enough to begin
with it's one of those things it's like
it's relying so much on those science
fiction cliches yeah i I'm a tad worried
especially because of love because of
Peter Dinklage is very sleepy voice but
just so you know there's more fallen and
hive on the way I totally see where
you're coming from but it doesn't bother
me quite that much because in the
broader scope of things like how the
world has so much personality my gosh
doesn't it it's so beautiful yeah it's
absolutely i think i spent half my time
just taking screenshots and uploading
them through the ps4 sharing systems and
then dying and then and then doc yes um
but you had like it's so gorgeous that's
kind of where you see the budget of that
game is just like God the crap it looks
amazing well I mean it sounds like we
both really enjoyed the destiny alpha
personally I'm interest interested to
see how much progression there is like
whether you keep finding really cool
loot at like level 10 level 20 level 30
like can it maintain that surprise and
delight because I feel like that's gonna
be where a lot of the strength of
totally wise is finding that really cool
[ __ ] and then showing it off in
multiplayer which I suspect is kind of
going to be the endgame component of
deaths Mariah's once you've done all the
stores right right and then you know the
addition of sub classes and things like
that I really want to see how different
I can be like how you need
I can feel especially as an MMO player
now destiny is not an MMO but it still
has some of those LMAO yeah it hits
those bees right and so I'm really
anxious to see like when when all when
all when all is said and done how
different how unique am I going to be i
mean i think the character creation
itself made me feel pretty different
from all the other people i ran into
back to the power so yeah yeah
absolutely see well there you have it
guys that's our take on the destiny
alpha make sure to stay tuned to
gamespot com for even more destiny
coverage coming your way over the next
few months